The following
content is provided
under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue
to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: OK.
Let's start.
So if we have been thinking
about critical points.
And these arise in
many phased diagrams
such as that we have for the
liquid gas system where there's
a coexistence line, let's say,
between the gas and the liquid
that terminate, or we looked
in the case of a magnet
where as a function of
[INAUDIBLE] temperature
there was in some
sense coexistence
between magnetizations
in different directions
terminating at the
critical point.
So why is it interesting
to take it a whole phase
diagram that we have over here?
For example, for this system, we
can also have solid, et cetera.
AUDIENCE: So isn't this
[INAUDIBLE] [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: [INAUDIBLE].
Yes.
Thank you.
And focus on just the one point.
In the vicinity
of this one point.
And the reason for that was
this idea of universality.
There many things
that are happening
in the vicinity of
this point as far
as singularitities,
correlations, et cetera,
are concerned that are
independent of whatever
the consequence
of the system are.
And these singularities, we try
to capture through some scaling
laws for the singularities.
And I've been kind
of constructing
a table of your singularities.
Let's do it one more time here.
So we could look at system
such as the liquid gas--
so let's have here
system-- and then we
could look at the liquid gas.
And for that, we can look
at a variety of exponents.
We have alpha, beta,
gamma, delta, mu, theta.
And for the liquid gas,
I write you some numbers.
The heat capacity
diverges with an exponent
that is 0.11--
slightly more accurate
than I had given you before.
The case for beta is 0.33 gamma.
OK.
I will give you a little
bit more digits just
to indicate the
accuracy of experiments.
This is 1.238 minus plus 0.012.
So these exponents are obtained
by looking at the fluid system
with light scattering-- doing
this critical opalescence
that we were talking
about in more detail
and accurately, Delta is 4.8.
The mu is, again from light
scattering 0.629 minus plus
0.003.
Theta is 0.032 0
minus plus 0.013.
And essentially these three are
[INAUDIBLE] light scattered.
Sorry.
Another case that I mentioned
is that of the super fluid.
And in this general
construction of the lambda
gives [INAUDIBLE]
theories that we had,
liquid gas would
be in question one.
Superfluid would
be in question two.
And I just want to mention
that actually the most
experimentally accurate exponent
that has been determined
is the heat capacity for dry
superfluid helium transition.
I had said that it kind of looks
like a logarithmic divergence.
You look at it very closely.
And it is in fact a cusp, and
does not diverge all the way
to infinity, so it corresponds
to a slightly negative value
of alpha, which is the
0.0127 minus plus 0.0003.
And the way that this
has been data-mined
is they took superfluid
helium to the space shuttle,
and this experiments
were done away
from the gravity of
the earth in order
to not to have to worry
about the density difference
that we would have
across the system.
Other exponents that you
have for this system--
let me write down--
beta is around 0.35.
Gamma is 1.32.
Delta is 4.79.
Mu is is 0.67.
Theta is 0.04.
And we don't need
this for system.
Any questions we could
do players kind of
add the exponents here
I've booked usability
even if it's minus
1 is a research data
0.7 down all those are long this
is more to say about new ideas
and so on I think is that
these numbers aren't you
think that is simplest
way for us is net
my position and the question
is why these numbers are all
of the same as all the
systems is therefore profound.
These are dimensionless numbers.
So in some sense, it is a
little bit of mathematics.
It's not like you calculate
the charge of the electron
and you get a number.
These don't depend on
a specific material.
Therefore, what is
important about them
is that they must
somehow be capturing
some aspect of the
collective behavior of all
of these degrees of freedom,
in which the details of what
the degrees of freedom
are is not that important.
Maybe the type of synergy
rating is important.
So unless we understand
and derive these numbers,
there is something important
about the collective behavior
of many degrees of freedom
that we have not understood.
And it is somehow a
different question
if you are thinking
about phase transitions.
So let's say you're thinking
about superconductors.
There's a lot of interest
in making high temperature
superconductor pushing TC
further and further up.
So that's certainly
a material problem.
We are asking a
different problem.
Why is it, whether you have a
high temperature superconductor
or any other type of system,
the collective behavior
is captured by the
same set of exponents.
So in an attempt to
try to answer that,
we did this Landau-Ginzburg and
try to calculate its singular
behavior using this other
point of approximation.
And the numbers
that we got, alpha
was 0, meaning that
there was discontinuity.
Beta was 1/2, gamma was 1,
delta was 3, my was 1/2,
theta was 0, which don't
quite match with these numbers
that we have up there.
So question is,
what should you do?
We've made an attempt and that
attempt was not successful.
So we are going to completely
for a while forget about that
and try to approach the problem
from a different perspective
and see how far we
can go, whether we
can gain any new insights.
So that new approach
I put on there
the name of the
scaling hypothesis.
And the reason for that will
become apparent shortly.
So what we have in common
in both of these examples
is that there is
a line where there
are discontinuities
in calculating
some thermodynamic
function that terminates
at a particular point.
And in the case of
the magnetic system,
we can look at the singularities
approaching that point either
along the direction
that corresponds
to change in temperature and
parametrize that through heat,
or we can change
the magnetic field
and approach the problem
from this other direction.
And we saw that there
were analogs for doing
so in the liquid
gas system also.
And in particular, let's say
we calculated a magnetization,
we found that there was one form
of singularity coming this way,
one form of singularity
coming that way.
We look at the picture
for the liquid gas system
that I have up there, and
it's not necessarily clear
which direction would
correspond to this nice symmetry
breaking or
non-symmetry breaking
that you have for
the magnetic system.
So you may well ask, suppose
I approach the critical point
along some other direction.
Maybe I come in along
the path such as this.
I still go to the
critical point.
We can imagine that for
the liquid gas system.
And what's the structure
of the singularities?
I know that there are different
singularities in the t and h
direction.
What is it if I
come and approach
the system along a
different direction,
which we may well do
for a liquid gas system?
Well, we could actually
answer that if we go back
to our graph saddlepoint
approximation.
In the saddlepoint
approximation,
we said that ultimately,
the singularities in terms
of these two
parameters t and h--
so this is in the saddlepoint.
Part obtained by minimizing
this function that
was appearing in the
expansion in the exponent.
There was a t over 2m squared.
There was a mu n to the 4th.
And there is an hm.
So we had to minimize
this with respect to m.
And clearly, what
that gives us is m.
If I really solve
the equation, that
corresponds to
this minimization,
which is a function of t and h.
And in particular, approaching
two directions that's
indicated, if I'm along the
direction where h equals 0,
I essentially balance
these two terms.
Let's just write this
as a proportionality.
I don't really care
about the numbers.
Along the direction
where h equals 0,
I have to balance m to
the 4th and tm squared.
So m squared will scale like e.
m will scale like
square root of t.
And more precisely,
we calculated
this formula for t
negative and h equals to 0.
If I, on the other hand,
come along the direction
that corresponds to t equals
to 0, along that direction
I don't have a first term.
I have to balance
um the 4th and hm.
So we immediately see that
m will scale like h over u.
In fact, more correctly h over
4u to the power of one third.
You substitute this
in the free energy
and you find that the singular
part of the free energy
as a function of t and h in
this saddlepoint approximation
has the [INAUDIBLE] to the
form of proportionality.
If I substitute this in
the formula for t negative,
I will get something
like minus t squared
over 4 we have-- forget about
the number t squared over u.
If I go along the t
equals to 0 direction,
substitute that over there,
I will get n to the 4th.
I will get h to the 4 thirds
divided by mu to the one third.
Even the mu dependence
I'm not interested.
I'm really interested in the
behavior close to t and h
as a function of t and h.
Mu is basically some
non-universal number
that doesn't go to 0.
I could in some sense
capture these two expressions
by a form that is
t squared and then
some function--
let's call it g sub
f which is a function
of-- let's see
how I define the delta
h over t to the delta.
So my claim is that I toyed
with the behavior coming
across these two different
special direction.
In general, anywhere else
where t and h are both nonzero,
the answer for m will be some
solution of a cubic equation,
but we can arrange it to
only be a function of h
over [INAUDIBLE]
and have this form.
Now I could maybe
rather than explicitly
show you how that
arises, which is not
difficult-- you can do that--
since there's something
that we need to
do later on, I'll
show it in the following manner.
I have not specified what
this function g sub f is.
But I know its behavior
along h equals to 0 here.
And so if I put h equals to 0,
the argument of the function
goes to 0.
So if I say that the
argument of the function
is a constant-- the constant
let's say is minus 1
over u on one side,
0 on the other side,
then everything's fine.
So I have is that the limit
as its argument goes to 0
should be some constant.
Well, what about
the other direction?
How can I reproduce
from a form such as this
the behavior when t equals to 0?
Because I see that
when t equals to 0,
the answer of course
cannot depend on t itself,
but as a power law
as a function of h.
Is it consistent with this form?
Well, as t goes
to 0 in this form,
the numerator here goes to 0,
the argument of the function
goes to infinity, I
need to know something
about the behavior of
the function of infinity.
So let's say that the limiting
behavior as the argument
of the function goes
to infinity of gf
of x is proportional to the
argument to some other peak.
And I don't know
where that power is.
Then if I look at this
function, the whole function
in this limit where t
goes to 0 will behave.
There's a t squared out
front the goes to 0,
the argument of the
function goes to infinity.
So the function will go like
the argument to some power.
So I go like h t to the
delta to some other peak.
So what do I know?
I know that the
answer should really
be proportional to h
to the four thirds.
So I immediately know that
my t should be four thirds.
But what about this delta?
I never told you what delta was.
Now I can figure out what delta
is, because the answer should
not depend on t.
t has gone to 0.
And so what power
of t do I have?
I have 2 minus
delta p should be 0.
So my delta should be 2
over p, 2 over four thirds,
so it should be three halves.
Why is this exponent relevant to
the question that I had before?
You can see that the function
that describes the free energy
as a function of
these two coordinates.
If I look at the combination
where h and t are non-zero,
is very much dependent on this
h divided by t to the delta,
and that delta is three halves.
So, for example, if
I were to draw here
curves where h goes like
3 to the three halves--
it's some coefficient, I don't
know what that coefficient is--
then essentially, everything
that is on the side
that hogs the vertical axis
behaves like the h singularity.
Everything that is over here
depends like a t singularity.
So a path that, for example,
comes along a straight line,
if I, let's say, call
the distance that I have
to the critical point
s, then t is something
like s cosine of theta. h is
something like s sine theta.
You can see however
that the information
h over t to the delta as
s goes to 0 will diverge,
because I have other
three halves down here
for s that will overcome the
linear cover I have over there.
So for any linear path that
goes through the critical point,
eventually for small s I will
see the type of singularity
that is characteristic
of the magnetic field
if the exponents are
according to this other point.
We have this
assumption, of course.
But if I therefore
knew the correct delta
for all of those systems, I
would be also able to answer,
let's say for the
liquid gas, whether if I
take a linear path that goes
through the critical point
I would see one set of
singularities or deltas
that have singularities.
So this delta which is
called a gap exponent,
gives you the answer to that.
But of course I don't
know the other exponents.
There is no reason for me
to trust the gap exponent
that I obtained in this fashion.
So what I say is let's assume
that for any critical point,
the singular part
of the free energy
on approaching the
critical point which
depends on this
pair of coordinates
has a singular behavior
that is similar to what
we had over here, except that
I don't know the exponent.
So rather than
putting 2 t squared,
I write t to the 2
minus alpha for reason
that will become
apparent shortly,
and some function of h t
to the delta and for some
alpha and delta.
So this is certainly
already an assumption.
This mathematically
corresponds to having
homogeneous functions.
Because if I have a
function of x and y,
I can certainly write lots of
functions such as x squared
plus y squared plus a constant
plus x cubed y cubed that I
cannot rearrange into this form.
But there are certain
functions of x and y
that I can rearrange
so that I can pull out
some factor of let's
say x squared out front,
and everything that
is then in a series
is a function of let's
say y over x cubed.
Something like that.
So there's some
class of functions
of two arguments that
have this homogeneity.
So we are going to assume that
the singular behavior close
to the critical point is
described by such a function.
That's an assumption.
But having made that assumption,
let's follow its consequence
and let's see if we
learned something
about that table of exponents.
Now the first thing
to note is clearly
I chose this alpha
over here so that when
I take two derivatives
with respect to t,
I would get something
like a heat capacity,
for which I know what
the divergence is.
That's a divergence
called alpha.
But there's one
thing that I have
to show you is that when
I take a derivative of one
of these homogeneous
functions, with respect
to one of its arguments,
I will generate
another homogeneous function.
If I take one derivative
with respect to t,
that derivative can
either act on this,
leaving the function
unchanged, or it
can act on the argument
of the function
and give me d to
the 2 minus alpha.
I will have minus h t to
the power of delta plus 1.
There will be a factor
of delta and then
I will have the derivative
function ht to the delta.
So I just took derivatives.
I can certainly pull
out a factor of t
to the 1 minus alpha.
Then the first term is
just 2 minus alpha times
the original function.
The second term is minus delta
h divided by t to the delta.
Because I pulled out
the 1 minus alpha,
this t gets rid of
the factor of 1 there.
And I have the derivative.
So this is completely
different function.
It's not the derivative
of the original function.
But whatever it is it
is still only a function
of the combination h
over t to the delta.
So the derivative of
a homogeneous function
is some other
homogeneous function.
Let's call it g2.
It doesn't matter.
Let's call it g1
ht to the delta.
And this will happen if I
take a second derivative.
So I know that if I
take two derivatives,
I will get t to the minus alpha.
I will basically drop
two factors over there.
And then some other
function, ht to the delta.
Clearly again, if I say
that I'm looking at the line
where h equals to
zero for a magnet,
then the argument of
the function goes to 0.
If I say that the function
of the argument goes to 0
is a constant, like
we had over here,
then I will have the singularity
t to the minus alpha.
So I've clearly engineered
whatever the value of alpha
is in this table,
I can put over here
and I have the right singularity
for the heat capacity.
Essentially I've put
it there by hand.
Let me comment on one
other thing, which
is when we are looking
at just the temperature,
let's say we are
looking at something
like a superfluid,
the only parameter
that we have at our disposal
is temperature and tens of ITC.
Let's say we plug
the heat capacity
and then we see divergence of
the heat capacity on the two
sides.
Who said that I should have
the same exponent on this side
and on this side?
So we said that
generally, in principle,
I could say I would do that.
And in principle, there
is no problem with that.
If there is function that
has one behavior here,
another behavior there,
who says that two exponents
have to be the same?
But I have said something more.
I have said that in all of
the cases that I'm looking at,
I know that there
is some other axis.
And for example, if I am
in the liquid gas system,
I can start from down
here, go all the way around
back here without
encountering a singularity.
I can go from the liquid
all the way to gas
without encountering
a singularity.
So that says that the system
is different from a system
that, let's say, has a
line of singularities.
So if I now take the
functions that in principle
have two different
singularities,
t to the minus alpha minus t to
the minus alpha plus on the h
equals to 0 axis and
try to elevate them
into the entire space by putting
this homogeneous functions
in front of them, there
is one and only one way
in which the two functions
can match exactly on this t
equals to 0 line, and that's if
the two exponents are the same
and you are dealing
with the same function.
So that we put in
a bit of physics.
So in principle, mathematically
if you don't have the h axis
and you look at the one line
and there's a singularity,
there's no reason why
the two singularities
should be the same.
But we know that we are
looking at the class
of physical systems where
there is the possibility
to analytically go from
one side to the other side.
And that immediately
imposes this constraint
that alpha plus should be
alpha minus, and one alpha
is in fact sufficient.
And I gave you the correct
answer for why that is.
If you want to see the
precise mathematical details
step by step, then
that's in the notes.
So fine.
So far we haven't learned much.
We've justified why
the two alphas should
be the same above
and below, but we
put the alpha, the one
alpha, then by hand.
And then we have this
unknown delta also.
But let's proceed.
Let's see what other consequence
emerge, because now we
have a function
of two variables.
I took derivatives
in respect to t.
I can take derivatives
with respect to m.
And in particular,
the magnetization
m as a function of
t and h is obtained
from a derivative of the free
energy with respect to h.
There's potential.
It's the response to
adding a field could
be some factor of
beta c or whatever.
It's not important.
The singular part
will come from this.
And so taking a derivative
of this function
I will get t this to
the 2 minus alpha.
The derivative of a
can be respect to h,
but h comes in the
combination h over t
to the delta will bring down a
factor of minus delta up front.
Then the derivative function--
let's call it gf1, for example.
So now I can look at this
function in the limit
where h goes to 0, climb
along the coexistence line,
h2 goes to 0.
The argument of the
function has gone to 0.
Makes sense that the
function should be constant
when its argument goes to 0.
So the answer is going
to be proportional to t
to the 2 minus
alpha minus delta.
But that's how beta was defined.
So if I know my beta
and alpha, then I
can calculate my delta from
this exponent identity.
Again, so far you
haven't done much.
You have translated two unknown
exponents, this singular form,
this gap exponent
that we don't know.
I can also look
at the other limit
where t goes to 0
that is calculating
the magnetization along
the critical isotherm.
So then the argument of the
function has gone to infinity.
And whatever the answer
is should not depend on t,
because I have said t goes to 0.
So I apply the same trick
that I did over here.
I say that when the
argument goes to infinity,
the function goes like
some power of its argument.
And clearly I have to choose
that power such that the t
dependence, since t is going
to 0, I have to get rid of it.
The only way that I can do
that is if p is 2 minus alpha
minus delta divided by that.
So having done that, the
whole thing will then
be a function of h to the p.
But the shape of
the magnetization
along the critical
isotherm, which was also
the shape of the isotherm
of the liquid gas system,
we were characterizing
by an exponent
that we were calling
1 over delta.
So we have now a
formula that says
my delta shouldn't in
fact be the inverse of p.
It should be the delta 2
minus alpha minus delta.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Why isn't
the exponent t minus 1
after you've
differentiated [INAUDIBLE]?
Because g originally was
defined as [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Let's call it pr.
Because actually, you're right.
If this is the same g and this
has particular singularity
[INAUDIBLE].
But at the end of the
day, it doesn't matter.
So now I have gained something
that I didn't have before.
That is, in
principle I hit alpha
and beta, my two exponents,
I'm able to figure out
what delta is.
And actually I can also
figure out what gamma is ,
because gamma describes
the divergence
of the susceptibility.
[INAUDIBLE] which is the
derivative of magnetization
with respect to
field, I have to take
another derivative
of this function.
Taking another derivative
with respect to h
will bring down another
factor of delta.
So this becomes minus 2 delta.
Some other double derivative
function h 2 to the delta.
And susceptibilities,
we are typically
interested in the limit
where the field goes to 0.
And we define them to
diverge with exponent gamma.
So we have identified gamma to
be 2 delta plus alpha minus 2.
So we have learned something.
Let's summarize it.
So the consequences--
one is we established
that same critical
exponents above and below.
Now since various
quantities of interest
are obtained by
taking derivatives
of our homogeneous
function and they
turn into homogeneous
functions, we
conclude that all quantities
are homogeneous functions
of the same combination
ht to the delta.
Same delta governs it.
And thirdly, once we make
this answer our assumption
for the free energy, we can
calculate the other exponents
on the table.
So all, of almost all other
exponents related to 2,
in this case alpha and delta.
Which means that if you have a
number of different exponents
that all depend
on 2, there should
be some identities,
exponent identities.
It's these numbers in the
table, we predict if all of this
is varied have some
relationships with t.
So let's show a couple
of these relationships.
So let's look at the combination
alpha plus 2 beta plus gamma.
Measurement of heat capacity,
magnetization, susceptibility.
Three different things.
So alpha is alpha 2.
My beta up there is 2
minus alpha minus delta.
My gamma is 2 delta
plus alpha minus 2.
We got algebra.
There's one alpha minus
2 alpha plus alpha.
Alpha is cancelled.
Minus 2 deltas plus 2
deltas then it does cancel.
I have 2 times 2
minus 2, so that 2.
So the prediction is that you
take some line on the table,
add alpha, beta, 2
beta plus gamma, they
should add up to one.
So let's pick something.
Let's pick a first--
actually, let's
pick the last line that
has a negative alpha.
So let's do n equals to 3.
For n equals to 3 I have
alpha which is minus .12.
I have twice beta, that is
.37, so that becomes 74.
And then I have
gamma, which is 1.39.
So this is 74.
I have 9 plus 413
minus 2, which is 1.
I have 3 plus 7, which is
10, minus 1, which is 9.
But then I had a 1 that was
carried over, so I will have 0.
So then I have 1, so 201.
Not bad.
Now this goes by the name
of the Rushbrooke identity.
The Rushbrooke made
a simple manipulation
based on thermodynamics and you
have a relationship with these.
Let's do another one.
Let's do delta and
subtract 1 from it.
What is my delta?
I have delta to the delta
2 plus alpha minus delta.
This is small delta
versus big delta.
And then I have minus 1.
Taking that into the numerator
with the common denominator
of 2 plus alpha minus
delta, this minus delta
becomes plus delta, which
this becomes 2 delta minus
alpha minus 2.
2 delta
AUDIENCE: Should that be a
minus alpha in the denominator?
PROFESSOR: It better be.
Yes.
2 delta plus alpha minus 2.
Then we can read off the gamma.
So this is gamma over beta.
And let's check this, let's
say for m equals to 2.
No, let's check it for m
plus 21, for the following
reason, that for n equals to
1, what we have for delta is
4.8 minus 1, which would be 3.8.
And on the other side,
we have gamma over beta.
Gamma is 1.24, roughly,
divided by beta .33,
which is roughly one third.
So I multiply this by 3.
And that becomes 3.72.
This one is known after another
famous physicist, Ben Widom,
as the Widom identity.
So that's nice.
We can start learning that
although we don't know anything
about this table, these are
not independent numbers.
There's relationship
between them.
And they're named after
famous physicists.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Can we briefly go
over again what extra assumption
we had put in to get
these in and these out?
Is it just that we have
this homogeneous function
[INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: That's right.
So you assume that
the singularity
in the vicinity of the
critical point as a function
of deviations from
that critical point
can be expressed as a
homogeneous function.
The homogeneous function, you
can rearrange any way you like.
One nice way to rearrange
it is in this fashion.
It will depend, the homogeneous
function on two exponents.
I chose to write
it as 2 minus alpha
so that one of the exponents
would immediately be alpha.
The other one I
couldn't immediately
write in terms of beta or gamma.
I had to do these
manipulations to find out
what the relationship
[INAUDIBLE].
But the physics of it is simple.
That is, once you know the
singularity of a free energy,
various other
quantities you obtain
by taking derivatives
of the free energy.
That's [INAUDIBLE]
And so then you
would have the singular
behavior of [INAUDIBLE].
So I started by saying
that all other exponents,
but then I realized we have
nothing so far that tells us
anything about mu and eta.
Because mu and eta
relate to correlations.
They are in
microscopic quantities.
Alpha, beta, gamma depend
on macroscopic thermodynamic
quantities, magnetization
susceptibility.
So there's no way that I will
be able to get information,
almost.
No easy way or no direct
way to get information
about mu and eta.
So I will go to assumption 2.0.
Go to the next version of the
homogeneity assumption, which
is to emphasize
that we certainly
know, again from physics
and the relationship
between susceptibility
and correlations,
that the reason
for the divergence
of the susceptibility is that
the correlations become large.
So we'll emphasize that.
So let's write our ansatz
not about the free energy,
but about the
correlation length.
So let's replace that
ansatz with homogeneity
of correlation length.
So once more, we
have a structure
where is a line
that is terminate
when two parameters,
t and h go to 0.
And we know that on
approaching this point,
the system will become cloudy.
There's a correlation
length that
diverges on approaching that
point a function of these two
arguments.
I'm going to make the same
homogeneity assumption
for the correlation length.
And again, this
is an assumption.
I say that this is
a to the minus mu.
The exponent mu was a divergence
of the correlation length.
Some other function, it's not
that first g that we wrote.
Let's call it g psi
of ht to the delta.
So we never discussed it,
but this function immediately
also tells me if you
approach the critical point
along the criticalizer term,
how does the correlation length
diverge through the various
tricks that we have discussed?
But this is going to be
telling me something more
if from here, I can reproduce
my scaling assumption 1.0.
So there is one other
step that I can make.
Assume divergence of
c is responsible--
let's call it even solely
responsible-- for singular
behavior.
And you say, what
does all of this mean?
So let's say that I have a
system could be my magnet,
could be my liquid gas that
has size l on each search.
And I calculate the
partition function log z.
Log z will certainly have
the part that is regular.
Well-- log z will have a part
that is certainly-- let's
say the contribution
phonons, all kinds
of other regular things
that don't have anything
to do with singularity
of the system.
Those things will give
you some regular function.
But one thing that
I know for sure
is that the answer is
going to be extensive.
If I have any nice
thermodynamic system
and I am in v
dimensions, then it
will be proportional to
the volume of that system
that I have.
Now the way that I have written
it is not entirely nice,
because log z is-- a log is
a dimensionless quantity.
Maybe I measured my length
in meters or centimeters
or whatever, so I
have dimensions here.
So it makes sense to pick some
landscape to dimensionalize it
before multiplying it by some
kind of irregular function
of whatever I have,
t and h, for example.
But what about
the singular part?
For the singular
part, the statement
was that somehow it was
a connective behavior.
It involved many, many
degrees of freedom.
We saw for the heat capacity of
the solid at low temperatures,
it came from long wavelength
degrees of freedom.
So no lattice parameter
is going to be important.
So one thing that I could
do, maintaining extensivity,
is to divide by l over
c times something.
So that's the only
thing that I did
to ensure that extensivity
is maintained when
I have kind of benign landscape,
but in addition a landscape
that is divergent.
Now you can see that
immediately that says that log
z singular as a
function of t and h,
will be proportional
to c to the minus t.
And using that
formula, it will be
proportional to t to the du,
some other scaling function.
And it's go back to
gf ht to the delta.
Physically, what it's
saying is that when
I am very close, but not
quite at the critical point,
I have a long correlation
length, much larger
than microscopic length
scale of my system.
So what I can say is that
within a correlation length,
my degrees of freedom for
magentization or whatever it is
are very much coupled
to each other.
So maybe what I can
do is I can regard
this as an independent lock.
And how many independent
locks do I have?
It is l over c to the d.
So the statement
roughly is a part
of the assumption is that this
correlation length that is
getting bigger and bigger.
Because things are
correlated, the number
of independent degrees
of freedom that you
are having gets
smaller and smaller.
And that's changing the
number of degrees of freedom
is responsible for the singular
behavior of the free energy.
If I make this assumption about
this correlation then diverges,
then I will get this form.
So now my ansatz 2.0
matches my ansatz 1.0
provided du is 2 minus alpha.
So I have du2 plus
2 minus alpha which
is known after Brian
Josephson, so this
is the Josephson relation.
And it is different from the
other exponent identities
that we have because
it explicitly
depends on the
dimensionality of space.
d appears in the problem.
It's called hyperscale
for that reason.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: So does the assumption
that the divergence in c
is solely responsible for
the singular behavior, what
are we excluding
when we assume that?
What else could happen that
would make that not true?
PROFESSOR: Well, what
is appearing here maybe
will have some singular
function of t and h.
AUDIENCE: So this
similar to what
we were assuming before when we
said that our free energy could
have some regular
part that depends
on [INAUDIBLE] the
part that [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Yes, exactly.
But once again, the truth
is really whether or not
this matches up
with experiments.
So let's, for example,
pick anything in that
table, v equals to t.
Let's pick n goes to 2,
which we haven't done so far.
And so what the formula
would say is 3 times mu.
Mu for the superfluid
is 67 is 2 minus-- well,
alpha is almost 0 but
slightly negative.
So it is 0.01.
And what do we have?
3 times 67 is 2.01.
So it matches.
Actually, we say, well,
why do you emphasize
that it's the
function of dimension?
Well, a little bit
later on in the course,
we will do an exact solution of
the so-called 2D Ising model.
So this is a system that
first wants to be close to 2,
n equals to 1.
And it was an important thing
that people could actually
solve an interacting problem,
not in three dimensions
but in two.
And the exponents
for that, alpha is 0,
but it really is a
logarithmic divergence.
Beta is 1/8.
Gamma is 7/4, delta is 15,
mu is 1, and eta is 1/4.
And we can check now
for this v equals to 2 n
equals to 1 that
we have two times
our mu, which exactly
is known to be
1 is 2 minus logarithmic
divergence corresponding to 0.
So again, there's
something that works.
One thing that you may
want to see and look at
is that the ansatz
that we made first also
works for the result
of saddlepoint,
not surprisingly because
again in the saddlepoint
we start with a singular free
energy and go through all this.
But it does not work for
this type of scaling,
because 2 minus alpha
would be 0 is not
equal to d times one half,
except in the case of four
dimensions.
So somehow, this
ansatz and this picture
breaks down within the
saddlepoint approximation.
If you remember what we did
when we calculated fluctuation
corrections for the
saddlepoint, you
got actually an exponent alpha
that was 2 minus mu over 2.
So the fluctuating part that
we get around the saddlepoint
does satisfy this.
But on top of that
there's another part that
is doe to the
saddlepoint value itself
that violates this
hyperscaling solution.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Empirically, how well
can we probe the dependence
on dimensionality that we're
finding in these expressions?
PROFESSOR:
Experimentally, we can
do d equals to 2 d equals to 3.
And computer simulations we
can also do d equals to 2 d
equals to 3.
Very soon, we will do
analytical expressions
where we will be
in 3.99 dimensions.
So we will be coming down
conservatively around 4.
So mathematically, we can
play tricks such as that.
But certainly empirically, in
the sense of experimentally
we are at a disadvantage
in those languages.
OK?
So we are making progress.
We have made our way
across this table.
We have also an identity
that involves mu.
But so far I haven't
said anything about eta.
I can say something about
the eta reasonably simply,
but then you try to
build something profound
based on that.
So let's look at exactly at
tc, at the critical point.
So let's say you are sitting
at t and h equals to 0.
You have to prepare your
system at that point.
There's nothing physically
that says you can't.
At that point, you can
look at correlations.
And the exponent eta for
example is a characteristic
of those correlations.
And one of the things that we
have is that m of x m of 0,
the connected parts-- well,
actually at the critical point
we don't even have to
put the connected part
because the average
of n is going to be 0.
But this is a
quantity that behaves
as 1 over the separation
that's actually
include two possible
points, x minus y.
When we did the case
of the fluctuations
at the critical point within
the saddlepoint method,
we found that the behavior
was like the Coulomb law.
It was falling off as
1x to the d minus 2.
But we said that
experiment indicated
that there is a small
correction for this
that we indicate
with exponent eta.
So that was how the
exponent eta was defined.
So can we have an identity
that involves the exponent eta?
We actually have seen
how to do this already.
Because we know that in
general, the susceptibilities
are related to integrals of
the correlation functions.
Now if I put this
power law over here,
you can see that the
answer is like trying
to be integrate x squared
all the way to infinity down.
So it will be divergent
and that's no problem.
At the critical point we
know that the susceptibility
is divergent.
But you say, OK, if I'm away
from the critical point,
then I will use this
formula, but only
up to the correlation length.
And I say that beyond
the correlation length,
then the correlations
will decay exponentially.
That's too rapid a falloff,
and essentially the only part
that's contributing
is because what
was happening at
the critical point.
Once I do that, I have to
integrate ddx over x to the d
minus 2 plus eta up to
the correlation length.
The answer will be proportional
to the correlation length
to the power of 2 minus eta.
And this will be proportional
to p to the power of c goes
[INAUDIBLE] to the minus mu.
2 minus eta times mu.
But we know that
the susceptibilities
diverge as t to the minus gamma.
So we have established
an exponent identity
that tells us that gamma
is 2 minus eta times mu.
And this is known as the Fisher
identity, after Michael Fisher.
Again, you can see that in
all of the cases in three
dimensions that we
are dealing with,
exponent eta is roughly 0.
It's 0.04 And all
of our gammas are
roughly twice what our
mus are in that table.
It's time we get
that table checked.
The one case that I have on
that table where eta is not 0
is when I'm looking at v
positive 2 where eta is 1/4.
So I take 2 minus
1/4, multiply it
by the mu that is
one in two dimension,
and the answer is
the 7/4, which we
have for the exponent
gamma over there.
So we have now the
identity that is
applicable to the
last exponents.
So all of this works.
Let's now take the
conceptual leap
that then allows
us to do what we
will do later on to
get the exponents.
Basically, you can see
that what we have imposed
here conceptually
is the following.
That when I'm away from
the critical point,
I look at the correlations
of this important statistical
field.
And I find that they
fall off with separation,
according to some power.
And the reason is that
at the critical point,
the correlation length
has gone to infinity.
That's not the length scale
that you have to play with.
You can divide x minus y divided
by c, which is what we do away
from the critical point.
c has gone to infinity.
The other length scale
that we are worried about
are things that go
into the microscopics.
but we are assuming that
microscopics is irrelevant.
It has been washed out.
So if we don't have
a large length scale,
if we don't have a short
length scale, some function
of distance, how can it decay?
The only way it can
decay is [INAUDIBLE].
So this statement is that when
we are at a critical point,
I look at some correlation.
And this was the
magnetization correlation.
But I can look at
correlation of anything else
as a function of separation.
And this will only fall off
as some power of separation.
Another way of writing
it is that if I
were to multiply this
by some length scale,
so rather than looking at things
that are some distance apart
at twice that distance
apart or hundred times
that distance apart, I will
reproduce the correlation
that I have up to some
other of the scale factor.
So the scale factor
here we can read off
has to be related to
t minus 2 plus eta.
But essentially, this
is a statement again
about homogeneity of
correlation functions
when you are at
a critical point.
So this is a symmetry here.
It says you take your
statistical correlations
and you look at them
at the larger scale
or at the shorter scale.
And up to some
overall scale factor,
you reproduce what
you had before.
So this is something to do
with invariance on the scale.
This scaling variance
is some property
that was popular a while
ago as being associated
with the kind of
geometrical objects
that you would call fractals.
So the statement is that
if I go across my system
and there is some pattern of
magnetization fluctuations,
let's say I look at it.
I'm going along
this direction x.
And I plot at some
particular configuration
that is dominant
and is contributing
to my free energy,
the magnetization,
that it has a shape that
has this characteristic self
similarity kind of maybe looking
like a mountain landscape.
And the statement
is that if I were
to take a part of that
landscape and then blow it up,
I will generate a pattern
that is of course not the same
as the first one.
It is not exactly
scale invariant.
But it has the same kind
of statistics as the one
that I had originally after
I multiplied this axis
by some factor lambda.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Under what length
scales are those subsimilarity
properties evident and how
do they compare to the length
scale over which you're
doing your course
grading for this field?
PROFESSOR: OK, so basically we
expect this to be applicable
presumably at length
scales that are
less than the size
of your system
because once I get to
the size of the system
I can't blow it up
further or whatever.
It has to certainly be
larger than whatever
the coarse-graining length is,
or the length scale at which
I have confidence that I have
washed out the microscoping
details.
Now that depends on
the system in question,
so I can't really give
you an answer for that.
The answer will
depend on the system.
But the point is
that I'm looking
in the vicinity of a point
where mathematically I'm
assured that there's a
correlation length that
goes to infinity.
So maybe there is some system
number 1 that average out
very easily, and
after a distance of 10
I can start applying this.
But maybe there's
some other system
where the microscopic degrees
of freedom are very problematic
and I have to go further and
further out before they average
out.
But in principle, since
my c has gone to infinity,
I can just pick a bigger and
bigger piece of my system
until that has happened.
So I can't tell you what
the short distance length
scale is in the same sense
that when [INAUDIBLE] says
that coast of Britain
is fractal, well,
I can't tell you whether
the short distance is
the size of a sand
particle, or is it
the size of, I don't know, a
tree or something like that.
I don't know.
So we started thinking
about our original problem.
And constructing
this Landau-Ginzburg,
[INAUDIBLE] that we worked
with on the basis of symmetries
such as invariance on
the rotation, et cetera.
Somehow we've discovered
that the point that we
are interested has an additional
symmetry that maybe we
didn't anticipate, which is
this self-similarity and scale
invariance.
So you say, OK, that's the
solution to the problem.
Let's go back to
our construction
of the Landau-Ginsburg
theory and add
to the list of
symmetries that have
to be obeyed, this additional
self-similarity of scaling.
And that will put us at t
equals to 0, h equals to 0.
And for example, we should
be able to calculate
this correlation.
Let me expand a little
bit on that because we
will need one other correlation.
Because we've said
that essentially,
all of the properties
of the system
I can get from two
independent exponents.
So suppose I constructed
this scale invariant theory
and I calculated this.
That would be on exponent.
I need another one.
Well, we had here a
statement about alpha.
We made the statement that
heat capacity diverges.
Now in the same sense that the
susceptibility is a response--
it came from two derivatives
of the free energy with respect
to the field.
The derivative of
magnetization with respect
to field magnetization is
one derivative [INAUDIBLE].
The heat capacity is
also two derivatives
of free energy with respect
to some other variable.
So in the same
sense that there is
a relationship between
the susceptibility
and an integrated
correlation function,
there is a relationship that
says that the heat capacity is
related to an integrated
correlation function.
So c as a function of say t and
h, let's say the singular part,
is going to be related to
an integral of something.
And again, we've
already seen this.
Essentially, you take one
derivative of the free energy
let's say with respect
the beta or temperature,
you get the energy.
And you take another
derivative of the energy
you will get the heat capacity.
And then that
derivative, if we write
in terms of the first derivative
of the partition function
becomes converted to
the variance in energy.
So in the same way that
the susceptibility was
the variance of the
net magnetization,
the heat capacity is
related to the variance
of the net energy of the
system at an even temperature.
The net energy of the
system we can write this
as an integral of
an energy density,
just as we wrote
the magnetization
as an integral of
magnetization density.
And then the heat capacity will
be related to the correlation
functions of the energy density.
Now once more, you say that
I'm at the critical point.
At the critical point
there is no length scale.
So any correlation function, not
only that of the magnetization,
should fall off as some
power of separation.
And you can call that
exponent whatever you like.
There is no definition
for it in the literature.
Let me write it in the
same way as magnetization
as d minus 2 plus eta prime.
So then when I go and say let's
terminate it at the correlation
length, the answer
is going to be
proportional to c to
the 2 minus eta prime,
which would be t
to the minus mu.
2 minus eta prime.
So then I would have alpha
being mu 2 minus eta.
So all I need to
do in principle is
to construct a theory,
which in addition
to rotational
invariance or there's
whatever is appropriate
to the system in question,
has this statistical
scale invariance.
Within that theory, calculate
the correlation functions
of two quantities, such as
magnetization and energy.
Extract two exponents.
Once we have two
exponents, then we
know why your
manipulations will be
able to calculate
all the exponents.
So why doesn't this
solve the problem?
The answer is that whereas I
can write immediately for you
a term such as m squared,
that is rotational invariant,
I don't know how to write down a
theory that is scale invariant.
The one case where people
have succeeded to do that
is actually two dimensions.
So in two dimensions,
one can show
that this kind of
scale invariance
is related to
conformal invariance
and that one can explicitly
write down conformal invariant
theories, extract exponents
et cetera out of those.
But say in three dimensions,
we don't know how to do that.
So we will still,
with that concept
in the back of our
mind, approach it
slightly differently by looking
at the effects of the scale
transformation on the system.
And that's the beginning of
this concept of normalization.